bonsoir les élections départementales se
dérouleront fin mars comment se prépare
le parti socialiste nouvelle défaite est
elle envisageable et si oui quelles
conséquences dans les yvelines l'ump
peut-elle réaliser le grand chelem comme
le souhaite l'actuel président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier nous
en reparlerons tout à l'heure avec
sandrine grand gambe la responsable du
ps dans les yvelines pour le moment
jacques ayer en plateau arnaud péricard
bienvenus vous êtes maire adjoint de
saint germain en laye en charge de la
culture ump également co fondateur du
club des loges c'est le sujet qui va
tout d'abord nous intéresser un club qui
fête ses deux ans et son but vous le
dites ce déjà pas être une officine
politique c'est important mais plutôt de
peser sur le territoire de quelle
manière
alors d'abord c'est un club d'élus
locaux personne n'est contre quelques
uns ne sont peut-être encartés c'est pas
une officine d'un parti politique c'est
au thunder dans ce droit qui centre au
centre centre-droit mais on a aussi des
personnalités de gauche on ne voyait pas
de sectarisme au sein de ce groupe tout
le monde est vraiment le bienvenu parce
que nos problématiques elles sont
locales alors vous parliez de peser dans
les choix ont varié on va essayer en
tout cas de peser dans les futures
élections départementales puisque
presque neuf candidats du club des loges
sont investis
pour ces élections cantonales pour le
coup par l'ump mais oui des idées un
dans certains cas et on a un certain
nombre de nos membres qui sont
aujourd'hui maire maire adjoint
parlementaire aussi dans les yvelines
donc on essaye de poser simplement en
essayant de faire entendre notre voix
qui est parfois une ou un petit peu
différente de celle des partis
politiques traditionnels
en quoi la voie différente parce que ce
sont des préoccupations locales
ce ne sont que des préoccupations
locales et les préoccupations locales
elles ne sont pas de droite ou de gauche
est sont bonnes nouvelles sont mauvaises
pour paraphraser un petit peu tony blair
qui disait ça donc forcément elles sont
peu rassemblé quels sont les sujets
concrets qui vont occuper cette ces deux
dernières années vous avez changé vos
compétences vos expériences je savais
monde et lui et qu'est ce qui est
ressorti on a ledge parquet comme on dit
nos pratiques ce que l'on fait de bien
et de moins bien dans certaines communes
en matière de sécurité de
vidéoprotection de petite enfance les
rythmes scolaires
ça a été on a passé plusieurs réunions
sur les rythmes scolaires on sera au
mois de février à rambouillet pour
parler de ruralité à ce que le
département des yvelines
ça n'est pas que la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin en yvelines où saint
germain en laye où versailles c'est
aussi un département rural un ensemble
de thématiques qui sont au coeur des
préoccupations des habitants de ce
département
parmi les différentes préoccupations
vous avez évoqué le département on va
venir au départemental mais
l'agrandissement des agglomérations par
exemple avec ces problématiques qui se
posent passé à huit cent mille habitants
s'étaient proposés par le préfet de
région ça se fait qu'ils étaient contre
mais globalement toute façon les
agglomérations de voir s'élargir en tant
qu'élus locaux
non je crois qu'il faut être responsable
moi je le constate simplement ma commune
à saint germain en laye on en est au
troisième périmètre en trois ans donc
c'est impossible de travailler en
synergie de dégager en tout cas des
projets en commun à une échelle
intercommunale
quand on change de périmètre tous les
trois ans il ya trois ans on était avec
asher conflent poissy et puis maintenant
on est à quai marie leroy le pecq
demain on sera avec sartrouville
montrent qu'elles sont on nous dit même
peut-être qu'on pourrait être avec
bezons qui est dans 95 dans le val
d'oise pas dans notre département je
crois que ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
quand même et pas beaucoup de de
cohérence alors oui à l'élargissement
bien évidemment oui au travail et comme
un oui à la réduction des dépenses mais
peut-être oui à la cohérence et à 7,7
cohérence et vous voulez
disais tout à l'heure je reviens au club
des loges à voir cet échange avec les
élus pour être sur les préoccupations
concrètes
combien d'élus aujourd'hui qu'on pose
justement le club des loges quelle
évolution ces deux dernières années
alors on a commencé ça s'appelle club
des loges parce que on a créé sa et
qu'olivier de la sphère il construit
général de versailles et l'ua à
versailles et karl olive keller possible
le maire de possibles autour d'un jarret
frites à la fête des loges alors c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle le club des
loges on était une petite dizaine d'élus
du mantois du versaillais du saint
germain hanoy du robot litre 1 et puis
on aujourd'hui près de 120 élus du
département landi jeunes élus bons
jeunes
on va dire jusqu'à quand en politique on
déjeune manuel valls disait qu'à 50 ans
on est toujours jeune en politique on va
dire entre entre 25 et 45 ans ou 50 ans
on peu près toutes les circonscriptions
tout est représenté pour un maillage
peuple alors vous serez dans toutes les
circonscriptions sont représentées on
aimerait justement touché un peu plus le
monde de la ruralité un cetain c'est un
département qui est vaste
donc c'est plus facile de sensibiliser
des élus qui sont par exemple ici
guyancourt montigny versailles le
mantois est très bien représentée toute
la vallée de la seine vous parliez tout
à l'heure de d'ouvrir la porte aux
jeunes en politique on va dire jusqu'à
quel jusqu'à 50 ans et vécut comment par
les plus âgés en politique vous êtes
exclu de manière variable qu'elle
pourrait on est on est bien accueilli
les sénateurs nous accueillent bien
parce qu'ils y voient ce réservoir
d'élus locaux qui se prennent un petit
peu en main certains voient ça d'un oeil
un peu plus un peu plus distant et ce
que l'on cherche à faire c'est vraiment
des rencontres avec les élus
on a été il ya quelques mois reçus par
pierre fons à sartrouville et
pierrefonds il a été emballé un peu par
notre approche qui est une démarche un
petit peu atypique n'ya pas de président
est pas directeur les pannes 10
président c'est vraiment un club amical
de travail et conviviale lorsque vous
dites on va s'occuper d'autres
préoccupations de chacun au quotidien
ont fait émerger les les plus jeunes les
plus anciens se disent pas un petit peu
ils sont prétentieux ces jeunes nous
aussi on sait faire de la politique mais
aussi on sait gérer nos communes aussi
il n'y a pas de raison la politique
c'est pas une question d'âge on n'a
jamais dit qu'il fallait faire du
jeunisme à tout prix on dit simplement
que on est un club de l'udc qui a envie
de se prendre en main 1 nous demander je
veux pas dire de ne pas demander la
permission à qui que ce soit mais se
prendre en main travailler ensemble il
ya peu de structures dans le département
où on peut échanger tous ensemble dans
un cadre convivial
alors on à l'union des maires des
yvelines on a des cadres des structures
qui existent oui mais on a des
structures qui sont un peu plus
institutionnel mais des structures des
changes où la parole est libre il y en a
un peu moins au sein de l'ump pour être
très précis valérie pécresse responsable
départemental plutôt contente de voir
émerger ce gros qu'elle est plutôt
contente c'est très conforme à la
démarche qu'elle a engagée faut pas
oublier que le renouveau l'eau le
renouveau des yvelines
enfin le renouveau de l'ump en tout cas
lors des dernières élections municipales
c'est elle qu'il a instigué qui l'a
propulsé il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes élus qu'elle a mis en place je
pense à l'heure en brosse je pense à
othman attrape à conflans et qu'elle a
réussi à mettre en place et qui ont
gagné leur combat par othman notre cas
le rembourse votre garçon justement sur
les listes qui ont été publiés dévoilé
sur les investitures pour les élections
départementales vous nous l'avez 19 9
candidats qui viennent de vos rangs du
club des loges justement c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui justement vous peser sur
les différentes instances j'espère qu'on
pèserait encore davantage
mais si on pèse c'est uniquement parce
que les gens qui ont les personnes qui
ont été choisis sont de bons candidats
ce sont des candidats qui ont su faire
leurs preuves notamment lors des
élections municipales précédentes ce
sont des élus de terrain et je crois que
la préoccupation de pierre bédier
aujourd'hui c'est de s'attacher dans le
cadre de ce renouvellement des lui parce
que cette élection elle est atypique en
ce qu'elle elle va permettre à toute une
nouvelle génération d'élus justement
d'arriver sur le devant de cette scène
départementale et je crois que tous les
candidats sont conformes un peu assez à
ces principes là renouvellement c'est un
mot important pour vous on vous l'avait
employée à plus d'une fois depuis depuis
tout à l'heure depuis ces différentes
ces quelques minutes qui se sont
écoulées
nicolas sarkozy son retour à l'ump je ne
fais pas être forcément très satisfait
c'est pas le juge n'a pas satisfait moi
je je je loue son énergie je loue son
charisme des élections pour la
présidence d'anne orale et ça c'est la
personne oui c'est cécile et samedi
prochains mois j'ai soutenu un autre
candidat
j'ai soutenu bruno le maire j'ai fait sa
campagne je les fais venir on l'a fait
venir avec les manuels d'amis à saint
germain le même soir que nicolas sarkozy
était à à vélizy on a fait une très
belle réunion je connais bruno depuis
longtemps j'aime son discours j'aime la
personnalité qu'ils aient j'aime la
progression
qu'il a kill kill et en ce moment ça ne
remporte pas le scrutin tels que je
pense qu'ils ont c'est grave oui il
gagnera très certainement pas le scrutin
mais je crois qu'il pèsera et on aura
besoin de lui à l'avenir et nicolas
sarkozy s'ils gagnent tous les sondages
denisot poids pas trahir de secret en
disant qu'ils risquent de gagner aura
besoin de personnalités comme bruno le
maire à ses côtés il y aura une union où
j'en suis persuadé je suis persuadé je
pense que la droite la plus bête du
monde je ne dis pas qu'elle est derrière
nous je vais pas faire de langue de bois
mais je pense que tout le monde a
compris qu'aujourd'hui face à l'as à la
situation et la gravité de cette
situation qu'il fallait que l'union soit
bel et bien présent tant que vous êtes
optimiste sur l'avenir de la vie
politique en france avec une ump est
pacifié qui va faire le point sur ces
différentes affaires qui va réussir à
s'unir aussi lent s'intéresse qu'à l'ump
un parti socialiste en apparence et ben
moi je les sens à tout ça ce sont des
préoccupations qui ne qui n'impacte pas
le militantisme le militantisme ump il a
fait ses preuves lors des derniers
scrutins on l'a vu aux élections
municipales
on le verra demain lors des élections
des parts départementales toutes ces
préoccupations de chef de la rue de
vaugirard vraiment ça ne nous intéresse
pas après ça a une incidence sur le vote
des électeurs les électeurs qui se
démobilisent aussi ceux qui ne sont pas
nécessairement encarté mais qui au final
sont importants le jour du scrutin
oui je crois qu'il faut c'est leur
responsabilité première c'est de
remobiliser justement ces militants cet
électorat s'ils ne le font pas ils
faillirent ont une dernière question
puisque vous êtes avocat de profession
vous avez eu pour enseignants barack
obama c'est objectif c'était de fermer
guantanamo sauver l'économie faire la
paix entre israéliens et palestiniens en
finir avec l'afghanistan réformer la
santé aujourd'hui la déception est au
moins à la hauteur des espoirs suscités
quel regard vous portez ça veut dire que
en politique avoir des espoirs ça ne
sert finalement pas à grand chose c'est
c'est difficile de concrétiser
non je crois qu'on est très injuste avec
barack obama ça a été un très grand
président c'est un président américain
qui a changé le regard du monde sur les
états unis après huit années de bushisme
comme on dit on
on s'en rendra peut-être pas compte
aujourd'hui mais dans quelques années on
en reparlera c'est un homme qui a eu que
c'est un homme de conviction qui a eu
des courage et d un courage politique
indéniable la santé il a fait ça lui a
coûté notamment les midterms le reste
c'est plus compliqué ouais c'est plus
compliqué il n'a pas eu de chance et de
tomber au milieu de cette crise
économique et financière mais je pense
qu'on se souviendra de lui comme un
comme un président qui aura changé le
regard du monde désespoir réaliser ses
espoirs concrétiser ses ambitions c'est
possible en politique donc il faut que
ces contrats en tout cas je sais pas je
ne sais pas si on peut y arriver mais il
faut le souhaiter
merci arnaud péricard co fondateur du
club des loges temps d'une courte
virgule et le 7-8 politique va continuer
juste le temps de vous annoncer que le
prochain invité du café politique se
sera alexandra rosetti la mary dei de
voisins-le-bretonneux l'émission a été
tournée à ce matin au bistrot du théâtre
à montigny elle sera à suivre dès ce
week-end sur notre antenne nous parlons
de son parcours ainsi que des principaux
dossiers qui concernent l sa commune il
sera aussi question départementale
les précédentes éditions des cafés
politiques avec les maires de montigny
elancourt guyancourt et la verrière sont
à revoir sur notre site internet
je reçois donc à présent au sandrine
grand gaube bonsoir responsable
départemental du parti socialiste le
parti socialiste dans les yvelines on va
parler des départementales avec vous
forcément tout d'abord cette information
le nombre d'adhésions serait en chute
libre au parti socialiste c'est europe 1
qui l'annoncé à la fin du mois d'octobre
en se basant sur les chiffres de cet été
la direction du ps qui n'avait pas
confirmé mais qui avait tout de même
évoqué une situation provisoire puisque
toutes les adhésions n'était pas encore
renouvelé aujourd'hui on est fin
novembre où en est on ne serait ce que
pour les yvelines j'ai pas beaucoup de
natifs tout simplement parce que les
reprises de cartes en général se font au
moment des votes
il se trouve qu'on va voter la semaine
prochaine donc c'est à ce moment là dans
ce combat vous savez bien
au niveau des adhésions ça se porte plus
tu as l'ensemble de l'année écoulée
donc on a un certainement une baisse je
ne vais pas le nier mais dans quel ordre
quelle ampleur je pense qu'elle est
largement en dessous de ce qui avait été
annoncé par la presse combien
d'adhérents aujourd'hui dans les
événements là aussi comme on a des
fichiers qui sont sur plusieurs années
on est à plus de 2000 adhérents et on a
là une vague d'adhésions qui continue il
y en a on a des jeunes notamment qui
continue au label encore le parti
socialiste sur la rd ainsi que des
militants des adhérents oui parce que
c'est dans ce genre de partie que les
choses se vont se jouer forcément vous
êtes en plateau pour parler de ses
prochaines échéances électorales les
départementales anciennement cantonales
actuellement au conseil général des
yvelines vous avez demi douzaine d'élus
est ce que vous serez en position de les
conserver mais ça on va tout faire pour
c'est le l'objectivité campagne
électorale ces deux demandes
particulières comme louis mais ses fins
il faut pas tout mélanger non plus les
les élections départementales c'est pour
défendre des sujets très très
particulier qui sont liées à l'action
sociale aux personnes âgées au handicap
et donc on a des conseillers généraux
sortants qui ont fait un gros travail
pas toujours facile donc on va valoriser
bien sûr ce bilan et puis on va partir
dans plein de canton en étant évidemment
dans une situation qui est pas simple
parce qu'on a des cantons très très
ancré à droite des grandes inégalités
sur ce département donc mais là aussi on
a toute une nouvelle génération qui a
envie de porter ces idées ces deux
élections qui mobilise peu ceci dit le
plus dur ça va être d'aller chercher ses
électeurs qui ne se déplace pas déjà
qu'ils ne se déplace pas en général et
encore moins pour les élections
seulement quand thomas c'est pour ça
qu'à mon avis il faut vraiment leur
parler des sujets qui les préoccupent
les histoires de politique nationale
politique politicienne cepal c'est pas
le propos c est ce qu'ils auront demain
un conseil général qui rapportait leur
parole au sein de l'assemblée
départementale
mais lorsqu'ils ont le sentiment je
pense soit pour les électeurs
socialistes en avoir été déçu par
rapport à la politique qui est menée
actuellement pour appliquer le même
raisonnement sonné à l'échelle du
département ils ont à dire pourquoi
aller voter pour le parti socialiste
finalement ce qui est promis et cet
aspect social n'est pas respectée sauf
que le département ça n'aura échappé à
personne n'est pas tenue par la gauche
et que donc c'est notre travail d'aller
expliquer à quoi sert le conseil général
et expliqué que la politique sociale qui
est menée aujourd'hui dans ce
département c'est la politique qui est
menée par pierre bédier et les équipes
qui sont avec lui donc l'ump il ya de
nombreux changements pour ce scrutin le
nombre de cantons qui s'est réduit
certains fusionnent et puis pour le
scrutin les électeurs vont se prononcer
pour un binôme hommes femmes qui vont
siéger la fin de favoriser cette parité
de la respecter enfin votre avis sur ces
deux réformes sur la réduction du nombre
de cantons et puis sur le binôme qui va
siéger au ca sur le binôme c'est ça
permet effectivement enfin d'avoir des
assemblées départementales qu'ils soient
plus à l'image de ce qu'est la france
c'est à dire avec la moitié de femmes
donc c'est quelque chose qui va dans le
bon sens même si moi je suis toujours
plutôt partisan de scrutin de liste et
de la proportionnelle mais l'idée en
tout cas de la parité est une bonne
chose
après sur les cantons qui ont été
agrandis on verra avec le dans le temps
mais c'est vrai qu'à priori avec la
réforme territoriale qui est en marche
de toute façon ces cantons n'ont pas
beaucoup d'avenir justement c'est encore
plus dur de mobiliser lorsqu on explique
aux électeurs comme vous venez de faire
l'axé quand on n'avait pas beaucoup
d'amis mais je dirais la famille c'est
ça alors là on est là pour dire la
réalité donc on n'est pas là pour mentir
aux gens et c'est vrai que là il ya
pendant un mandat une action apportée
notamment je disais sur sur le social
puisque c'est la compétence des
départements et ensuite ses compétences
là seront de redistribuer entre les
intercommunalités et la région on parle
par exemple des collèges qui pourrait
revenir à la région donc ça sera aussi
notre eux d'expliquer tout ça ça veut
dire vous minimisez ce scrutin si le ps
échoue finalement c'est pas grave
puisque les départementales ça va pas
durer très longtemps et puis les
départements disparaîtront non parce que
tu chaque élection est importante et sa
vaisselle sont importantes pour saluer
parce que tout processus démocratique
est important c'est le moment unique on
va voir les électeurs ou
et
on voit aussi ce dialogue qui se nouent
donc bien sûr que c'est des élections
toute élection pour moi est importante
après c'est vrai que c'est un scrutin
qui nous est pas forcément très
favorable en général l'ump lui dès
qu'ils se sont mis d'accord pour les
investitures parfum de minimiser
justement les pertes des lecteurs le
front national qui a fait une
progression notamment lors des
européennes le dernier scrutin
bipolarisation aujourd'hui qui pourrait
s'effectuer au sein du département entre
la droite et l'extrême droite
c'est un risque et ça vous inquiète et
encore une carte à jouer pour le ps bref
quand même dernières élections
régionales la gauche fait 49 % sur le
département dont on voudrait pas non
plus imaginer le dernier scrutin
européen le parti socialiste a fait
passer l'information c'est pour ça que
voir les blacks comme on dit c'est pour
ça qu'il faut et qu'il faut prendre
élection après élection il ya des
tendances on sait bien que la sur le
plan national la situation n'est pas
simple pour la gauche mais il faut il
faut pas mélanger non plus les scrutins
donc moi je
ce qui m'inquiète c'est ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la montée du front
national mais ça ça m'inquiète bien sûr
après l'autre difficulté c'est que la
loi dit qu'il faut douze ennemis % des
inscrits pour se maintenir au deuxième
tour
donc ça aussi ça impose de faire un
rassemblement le plus large à gauche des
premiers toi je parlais des alliances
entre l'ump et lui dit les centristes
pour cette départementale vous avez fait
l'union déjà pour les investitures avec
vos alliés naturels de gauche on
travaille c'est ça va se faire ça se
fait quand on part quand on en fait un
don qu'il ya des discussions qui se noue
la hoya prioritairement des sortants
pour voir comment on peut travailler
ensemble et évidemment nous on appelle
un large rassemblement de la gauche
parce que l'enjeu c'est effectivement
d'être au deuxième tour dans certains
cantons
mais quand vous dites que vous y
travaillez ça veut dire que ce n'est pas
encore acté c'est difficile à observer
un set ce consensus aux arabophones
on a notre calendrier qui est que
on désigne les candidats socialistes
simplement la semaine prochaine donc on
va faire ce processus là où on sait
qu'il ya des enjeux particulièrement
important je pense par exemple aux
cantons andrésy morcourt conflent il ya
un élu sortant ps 1 élus sortants verts
on va prendre le temps de la discussion
avec des des discussions sur le fond sur
les projets locaux qui sont qui sont à
débattre à défendre ensemble sur le
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment
discussions canton alors sur le canton
d'elancourt qui concerne l encours
trappe la verrière le maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous qui sera candidat à
la candidature continue alors ce que
j'ai nous d'avoir notre propre
calendrier germain nous met je sais bien
que le département allait vous voyez je
vois bien que
on a l'habitude de se caler sur 15
départements sur le calendrier de
monsieur bédié mais nous on a encore
notre calendrier est notre façon de
faire donc on respectera ça et c'est pas
parce que les candidats de droite sont
mariés annoncé qu'elle serait candidate
le décès mais l'idée c'est de soutenir
par tous nos sortants quand ils veulent
se représenter il ya des cas où il ne se
représenteront pas rimbaud sylvestre a
déjà annoncé qu'il ne se représenterait
pas locaux quand on la met sur s'insérer
sur saint cyr l'école par exemple la
candidature du maire philippe benassaya
maire de bois d'arcy qui couvre aussi ce
secteur on a un sortant qui s'appelle
jean climat les caf un excellent
entraîneur donc ça nous inquiète pas
lorsqu'on voit justement ça je vous pose
ces questions c'est que ce sont des
mères qui ont été élus avec une forte
majorité qui vont avoir sans doute une
base assez solide dans leur commune déjà
pour ces élections
ce sont des cantons que j'ai est riche
en deux ans philippe mallet a été élu
face au maire de fontenay qui était
candidat à l'époque donc que sa fin je
vais vous dire que ça va être simple on
sait bien que ça va être difficile mais
sait pas dans quelle situation sera en
mars et et puis on va faire campagne
après le scrutin des départementales
avant celui des régionales il y aura au
cours de l'été jean 2015 juste avant
l'été le congrès du ps en bas d'un
congrès de clarification vous en
attendez quoi en tant que responsable
départemental dans les yvelines on est
dans la vie normale d'un parti politique
c'est la vie démocratique de notre parti
de faire des congrès de las quand on
parle de congrès de la clarification
c'est que y'a quand même des discussions
entre deux tendances qui sont pas
forcément très d'accord et qu'il ya des
choix très nette à prendre quelle
qu'elle soit vous souhaitez prendre est
ce que pour être très clair la ligne du
gouvernement vous satisfait est ce que
vous préfériez une ligne comme benoît
hamon qui soit plus à gauche on va dire
benoît hamon qui y siège d'ailleurs au
conseil municipal de trappes avec vous
la question ça sera pas pour ou contre
le gouvernement à notre congrès c'est
sur des idées et que je sois dans une
logique de soutien aux idées devenue un
monde c'est pas
scoop bien secret donc vous soutiendrez
si par exemple il était candidat sur ce
congrès pour reprendre la présidence si
c'est dans une logique de rassemblement
et que ça a du sens oui afin d'écouter
les militants du ps le il ya aussi à des
états généraux qui ont été lancés pour
redéfinir l'identité du parti un
rassemblement qui viendra clore tout ça
le 6 décembre
il est possible aujourd'hui de faire une
union de ces différentes tendances du ps
mais parce que l'ale la question s'était
pas de trancher sur une ligne ou sur sur
ce que pourrait être un projet demain
pour la gauche c'était de refaire le
point sur c'est quoi être socialiste
aujourd'hui donc on est plutôt dans la
définition d'une identité d'une charte
qu'est-ce qui est notre socle commun
donc et heureusement qu'on est capable
de se mettre d'accord sur ces éléments
là mais justement pour vous c'est quoi
être socialiste aujourd'hui c'est met en
avant toujours la notion d'égalité et de
justice sociale
merci sans rubin responsable du parti
socialiste dans le département d'être
venu ce soir
cette lutte politique reviendra à la fin
du mois de décembre 23 décembre je
recevrai notamment philippe chevrier le
responsable départemental du front
national je vous retrouve aussi et
chaque soir en direct à 18 heures pour
la première diffusion du journal du
lundi au vendredi ce très bonne soirée